I turn my camera on I cut my fingers on
the
way hello
everyone my name is sorus and those of
you in Singo might know that I'm a not
developer and I'm active in the local
Singapore JS
Community right now I'm finishing my
study in the National University of
Singapore and today I'm going to talk
about web framework architecture and
also my project
quer now be before I begin I believe
some of you in the audience might think
of this no way not another web framework
and you are rightfully so because we all
share the same frustration that there
have been too many web Frameworks around
with new ones still been created almost
every
day but I also like like to take this as
an opportunity for us to think a bit
deeper on why do we use
Frameworks why are there so many of them
what are their problems and is there any
better ways to create web
applications I believe most of us here
in some way one way or
another will have chosen a particular
web framework to help us build our web
application and there can be me many
reasons behind our choice
but in general we choose a framework
because it is easy to use and also it
seems to solve all our
problems there's also a high chance that
the framework we chose would be what's
called an MVC
framework and we know all know what is a
MVC pattern and in
fact the MVC pattern is so prominent
today in our generation that it seems to
be the answer to everything
but also the source of all
hatred I always
wondered that if the MVC pattern is so
great and so elegant why are there so
many different MVC implementations each
having the um MBC implementation that
incompatible with each
others to understand that let's take a
quick recap on what is model view and
controller the NVC is a very simple
pattern that makes us makes it very easy
for us to solve certain program domains
for example it lets us group database
persistent logic such as SQL queries to
the model domain and also the
presentation logic such as templating to
the view
domain even though MVC is a very simple
pattern the real world is much more
complicated than that
and and the problems cannot be just fit
into just three
categories in fact there are many other
problems that there are many other
problems that do not fall into a scope
of MVC and there's no clear consensus on
how we can solve these
problems and this is usually where web
Frameworks diverge and they will solve
these problems in non-standard ways and
sell this as a features of their
framework
and as developers it becomes that we
choose a framework based on the feature
leas to suit our
needs and the name MVC is just there as
a distraction for
us to obscure the fact that we are
chosing the
features our current application and
framework design also do not fit well in
the modern web
architecture today we've advanced in
cloud computing we can have thousands of
Serv instances running on the
cloud and of these instances there are
many other application Types on top of
our core applications such as the
database server or main cat server or
red and all these other applications
they can be skilled independently in
different
ways but at the core most of our code
are still resite on the main
application which is designed as if they
are running as a mon as a single piece
of software on a on one server like in
the 90 eras and the only way to scale
this is by scaling them
horizontally with many instances of the
application server running the same
code now while this solve the problem
there should be better way to scale the
core of our main application for example
by breaking them down to smaller
subsystems
sometimes this concept is also called
microservices but we cannot achieve that
level of
modularity if our core application is
designed as a monolithic piece of
software now MVC is a great pattern and
I'm not suggesting that we should
abandon
MVC but we have to also think Beyond MVC
and go down to the architecture level so
that we can find a generic architecture
that can be applied the same way through
all the problem domain we face while
keeping our application
modular and the middleware architecture
is the solution that I would like to
highlight
today if you search the internet there
are many vague definition on what a
middleware really is but I find the
definition I shown here to fit the fit
the best and here is how it
works at the core of a middleware
architecture is made of a
application which can be a function or
an object or
program that perform some standard
operation such as handling htb
request and and with that we can have a
meterware that rubs around an
application which can intersect the
input and output of this applic
to modify Its
Behavior for example a middleware can
modify the request before the
application received it as well as
changing the response that is returned
by an
application a meterware can also capture
any error raised by the application and
recover it recover from it by generating
its own
response we can have many layers of
middle west each rub around another to
form a of complex
applications and this is a very powerful
construct that often hidden in plain
sight beneath many of the web
applications we use
today it's common that in our
applications features such as htb
compression and session management are
implemented as
middleware
in fact mware is the universal
architecture that can be found across
many different languages and
platforms at a low level of HTTP servers
such as Apachi and Eng X they have their
own middleware system that's also
sometimes called
Fs in Python there's this standard
called the web server Gateway interface
or wsgi in short they allow python
applications to have a universal way to
interface with the web
servers there's also a similar interface
in Ruby which is called
Rec they allow Ruby applications and
Frameworks including reals to run on top
of
it the wsgi and Rec standards they also
enable a power the powerful middleware
architecture
they allow web applications on top to
use the same mware regardless of the
particular framework they
choose now so mware is a powerful way to
extend web
applications however there's a high
barrier in implementing and using metw
properly today as compared to just
simply writing code using a high level
framework
this is because the current middleware
standards are quite low level for
instance the wsgi and Rec standard they
modeled after the CGI standard which is
invented in the
1990s and as for the Apachi and engine X
the medware implementation have to be
written in C require compiler to chain
and sometime even rout access just to
change the
configuration to take mware to its full
potential we have to break this barrier
and allow middleware to be used easily
at all
levels and this is where note comes to R
skill ever since ryal invented node node
has an important advantage that node
itself is already the web
server with the powerful lip UV Library
that allow node to perform asynchronous
IO
operation and the natural asynchronous
programming style in
JavaScript node itself can be run as a
powerful high performance web server
without the help of conventional servers
such as
Apachi node also by default comes with a
standard Handler interface which is
defined as a simply as a p
function and all the HTTP and
application code can be run in the same
environment namely in
JavaScript so since node have all this
Advantage we as a node developers should
live a happily
afterlife
right unfortunately not so
simple because there are still some
weaknesses in the current node Handler
design and we can demonstrate that by
having a greet Handler example that
having a Handler that greets the user
with a configurable GD
work now because of the lack of a
dependency management solution in
node anything that needs configuration
usually have to get the configuration
from a global
location and that makes it hard to
separate the application in into a
different configuration
environment the dependent the the
intermediary result stored by middle
west such as a user
information also have be to be mixed
with the request object because there's
no other way for a meterware to pass
down intermediary information to the
Handler and this makes the request
object complicated and hard to on
understand at the core of this code the
actual application logic is actually
made of just one line of code which is
constructing the string that greets the
user and the remaining lines are just
boiler plates that contain HTTP specific
Logic for returning the response and to
generate the response the Handler code
have to perform imperative action to the
response
object and all this together makes it
quite hard to implement a meterware
architecture on top of node
Handler for
example if you want to implement a git
middleware that compress a HDTV response
generated by a nodee Handler how can we
do
it we can use the current Express
middleware standard which is a
middleware system in
node and by having defining a middleware
function with an additional next
parameter and the first step of this
middleware is straightforward which is
to check the accept encoding header in
the
request this because the request Header
information is already available by the
time this middleware function is
called but the next step is not so
straightforward because this mware it
has to set the content encoding response
heer of the
response as well as compressing the
response
stream but the response result is not
yet been written by the Handler because
it's not yet been called and even when
it's called the Handler would write its
result to the response object directly
as a result the middleware has to resort
to some ugly hex in order to work around
this and somehow intersect the content
before it is actually
written the next function is also an
opaque function with no clear semantics
of where the mware is going
next this makes it hard for middleware
to perform some uncommon operations such
as calling the original Handler twice or
such as error recovery which the
middleway will have to check whether the
response had been written halfway when
the error was
thrown so one object main objective for
me to create quiver is to implement an
easy to use met Bas mware based
architecture and try to apply this
middleware concept to
everything including application logic
such as permission
control on top of this qu also come with
many other
features that makes it even easier to
create we
applications it used the egas script 6
which is the next JavaScript
standard and he has its own stream
design following the CSP
style qu has a dependency management
solution built in and also he has a
powerful declarative component
system I'll go through each one of them
and
eventually you you can create a
application using quer structure
something like the one I shown here and
I'll explain how it works in the
end at the foundation qua is made of six
Foundation constructs which I will go
through each of them now from the
starting from the
bottom first thing quer have its own
stream
implementation to fix some of the
existing problems in the existing not
stream instead of following the current
stream design the quer stream channel
follow this communication sequential
process
model or CSP in short that is invented
by Tony Hall to manage concurrent
process this channel concept is also
similar to the channel construct in go
length for those of you who are familiar
with
it qu stream channel is also have a
promise based control F and more
importantly it has back pressure
support let's see how we can create a f
stream using a quiver
stream the first thing in the
function it will use the quiver Channel
Constructor to create a pair of readr
stream and then return the r stream to
the
caller the function also keeps the right
stream private to itself and it would it
can then
asynchronously read the buffer from a
file
system and simply write WR it to the
right stream which then the buffer can
be automatically delivered to the r
stream the quer stream channel design
makes it very easy to perform stream
transformation which is a very hard task
in the current no stream
design for example to implement a
transform stream function that modifies
the stream buffer content
the function can accept a r stream
object create a pair of new readr stream
and return the new R stream to the
column it can then perform this pipe
transform operation in the background by
continuously reading the buffer from the
read stream perform some transformation
and then just write it back to the new
right
stream and the above code demonstrates
how this pipe transform works
first of all qua also provide this es6
generator rer
function to allow us to write a
synchronous code in synchronous fashion
you using the es6
generator with an additional U keyword
to a synchronous function
calls this allows the code piping code
to Simply implemented in a w Loop and
the being can optionally support back
pressure by calling the right stream
prepare right
method this would suspend the code until
the purple R stream at the other end is
ready to be
read both the prepare right and read
method of the streams also return their
result as promises containing object
with d structured
result inside one of these result is the
Clos flag which is is used to indicate
the end of either stream which then the
piping can
stop with this new
stream Quiva also split the original
Handler definition into two new types of
handlers the first type of handlers is
called a stream Handler which is used to
implement code that contain only
application
logic and if your application code
contain HTTP logic as well you can use
the more complicated version which is
the HTTP
Handler the stream Handler also accepts
an arcs planee object in addition to the
input stream to allow inter to allow
middle west to to put in intermediary
results and as for the htdv Handler it
also separate out the request and
response hit from the the body so as to
allow easier manipulation by midle
West you will also notice that both the
handers they accept and return what's
called a streamable object in quiver and
a streamable is essenti essentially a
stream light object with a two stream
method to convert the stream streamable
into a r stream but the streamable can
also have other optional methods such as
to text and to
Json to allow it to convert to other
representation in optimized way without
the overhead of paring the entire raw
stream
content here we call the conversion from
a stream to string to be two text to
avoid name cision with the buil-in
JavaScript to string
method here is a simple example of how
we can can Implement a hello Handler
inquiver the intermediary result of this
Handler is is retrieved from the ax plan
object and once constructing the stre
string the Handler can use the text to
stream mobile helper function to convert
any string to a streamable object and
then simply return
it and the Stream and the stream hander
design in quiver follow closely with the
Unix process
model which allow quer to take full
advantage of the Unix philosophy and
things such as Unix
pipeline next the hdp
Handler can also be implemented in
similar ways and here is an example of
hdp Handler passing form post
data and notice in the last line to
create a the response the HTTP Handler
returns its result as a two element
array with the first element being the
response hit which can be created just
like any ordinary
object in the second arguments we call
the empty streamable helper function to
create an empty body for the
response on top of
hras qu also have a simple solution to
solve the dependency manag ment problem
using the con Builder construct a
builder is simply a function that
accepts a config plane object and return
a handle function and using
that a builder can capture
configurations such as a grid word in
this case and then return a function
that can then capture the grid word in
the form of closure variable
access on top of this quiver have this
filter construct which implements the
middleware pattern that I described
earlier and a filter has a similar
signature as Builder that it accept a
config plane object as first argument so
as to make the filter
configurable but also the original
Handler as a second
argument the filter function then
returns a filtered Handler function that
rubs the original hand Handler
inside using that we can perform task
such as permission
control which then would check whether
the user is administrator and if it pass
it will just simply forward the request
to the Handler by calling it as a
function
called the quer filter
design is is made to allow maximum
control of the filter on all the
behaviors of
handers and with that we can easily
Implement a filters such as the HTP
compress filter that we
described
earlier inside
here our HD our compression filter would
as usual to check the accept encoding
request
header and the for the next step it will
call the original Handler and get back
its result as a two
element array containing the
response and because this response hit
and response stream they are just plain
object that has not been written to the
wire a hdb filter can perform modify the
response hit such as adding the content
encoding header to it with no further
complication it can also compress the
response
Body by creating a new Stream mobile out
of it and when returning it will replace
the response body with this new Stream
mobile while keeping the response hit
the
same now the quer filter implements the
middleware pattern that described and
the reason is called filter is because
quival middleware is something a bit
more
powerful by adding one extra word to the
definition equival meterware is a
function that accept a
configuration and the or the the
original Handler Builder as a second
argument and this
allows the middleware to not only extend
the behavior of the constructed Handler
but also affect how the Handler itself
is
constructed and with that we can build
middlewares such as the database
middleware which would then extract
database credentials from the
config instantiate a database instance
and then inject it back to the
configurate config object before passing
it to the original Builder function
this is essentially dependency injection
solve in quiver and the advantage of
this approach is
twofold at a
builder a builder function
implementer can just make use of the
database instance directly without
knowing how to instantiate
it and as for the and as for the
caller it can just pass it In The Raw
database credentials without having to
boil down to the database construction
code all these I have described are the
foundation constructs in quiver and on
top of it there's a component system to
provide a easy way to declare these
constructs as components and combine
them
easily for example here we can use the
quer component system to create a
simplified type of
handr using this simpler Handler Builder
function
provided and it allows the simplified
handle type to accept and return
simplified objects such as string and
Json that's automatically converted from
streamer
Works in this case we are defining a a
GD Handler
component and because it ignores the
input stream the input type is
void and because it Returns the result
as string the output type is
text the entire Expressions returns a
Handler
component which can then be used later
on and the reason we call it grid
Handler instead of GD Handler component
is for Simplicity in
naming
once we Define a component we can easily
instantiate them by using the load
Handler method on the
component this will return a Handler
function that can later be consumed by
simply use it as a function
call and this has a important
implication which is that quiver
handlers both the stream and HTP
handlers can be consumed internally
without the requirement of
network and this makes it very easy for
us to unit test it as well as for allow
the handers to have dependencies on each
others once we have multiple components
defined we can combine them easily using
the component
system let's say we have a permission
filter defined in some other source
file we can then simply import them and
apply it to the GD handle component by
calling the middleware
method this extended grid
Handler can also be mounted on a newly
created router
component which will then extract the
name out from the parameterized
URL a hand a components can simply be
run as a server by calling this start
server helper
function
and using quer we can create very
complex application by forming component
graphs consist of hundreds of
components and in a typical setting we
will have a main router component as an
entry point to handle all HTTP
requests the main router can also
forward some sub routes to a sub
router for
handling
and at the end we can have handers such
as user info Handler to to serve user
profiles in Json
format the user info
Handler can depend on
database and it can have the database
middleware to inject this
dependency let's say we have an View
Post Handler that serve block post
content this View Post Handler might
want to check for permission to allow
only certain readers to read and it can
be done by using a permission
filter and for this permission filter to
get the user information before deciding
it can have direct dependency to the
user info Handler itself and consume it
just like a rest
API the main router can also have other
path such as serving images and usually
we want to resize images before serving
to save some bandwidth and this can be
done by having a pipeline
Handler inside this pipeline the first
component would get the file the image
file from some Source such as a file
Handler and the content will be resized
by forwarding it to a image resize
Handler and because image resizing is a
expensive operation the entire result
can be cached using a cach
filter so that the image only need to be
resized
once and a common HTTP filter can be
applied on the main router and it will
affect all the sub handle components
inside the quer component system also
make it very easy to Plug and Play
replace a
component for
example because image resizing is very
expensive we can offload it to some
external server and replace the or
resizing with a proxy
component so in
summary we learned that middleware is
the universal architecture that can be
found in many
platforms and qu want to take this m
concept to the next level by applying it
to
all to everything including application
logic we've known qu also blur the
boundary between HTTP and application
code and allow them to all live in the
same
system right now I finished the
foundation architecture of quer and also
the component system to allow defining
components the next step is to implement
core components that provide features
that are commonly
found in web application such as
templating and
authentication it is only after all
these components have been done then
only we can create easily create web
applications by simply combining these
components I've only shared about quer
to the local Singapore
community and right now I would like to
take this as a chance to have a beta
launch at GS conon so do will help me
spread the word on the
internet any feedback and contribution
is welcome and if you are really
interested in my architect
do join me as a core developers so that
we can together take quer to The Next
Step thank you very
much